we actually do have new merch this time
uh we have the new Comfort colors tees
for the uh be good to yourself in Fall
colors like light green brick midnight
and multi-black
find that in more at theovanstore.com
we also have some shows upcoming in Las
Vegas October 27th and 28th Norfolk
Virginia
November 9. and Huntsville Alabama
November 19 in Atlanta Georgia November
29 and 30th you can get those tickets
all of them at theovan.com t-o-u-r
today's guest is out of St Louis
Missouri and we're happy to get to spend
some time with her uh she got everything
going brazy as they say uh you're gonna
get to know her just like I am uh we're
down here in Miami spending some time
with sexy red
[Music]
thank you
sit and tell you my stories
I don't know
and I will find a song
[Applause]
the candle I think we got it from uh
maybe uh black and white you know that
store no or no it's uh
um
I don't know it's like a I think a
woman's store you smell good oh yeah I
love secret scent you like teak wood
yeah
it's kind of romantic yeah that's my
favorite scene my candles or cologne or
something good right I don't know if I
ever worn any teak wood I should put
some on sometimes
do you have a lot of candles at home
yeah
and what about um
what about uh like what else do you like
to keep at home that makes you feel good
um I like candles air freshener
I don't know because when you clean up
and eat like a candle and then you chill
it's just saying yeah it feels like you
won huh yeah yeah
uh nice to see you today thanks nice to
see you you look lovely congratulations
on your success thank you appreciate
that your world's kind of changing huh a
lot you know it is
it kind of scary some of it yeah I use
the artists for real maybe a lot
tiring too people don't realize I think
your dreams and then once you get your
dreams you still have to do your dreams
yeah you still got to chase them and
stuff yeah it'd be a lot that come with
this stuff people don't be knowing but
it'd be
be a lot of footwork you gotta put into
it and stuff yeah it's a lot of motion
speaking of footwork I saw people on the
run from those floods do you see those
floods they had in New York you didn't
see it man was a flood oh they got some
wet ass pavement look at this [__]
damn when was this
this I ain't never seen no flood in New
York
the Lord coming for everybody
[Music]
no that's crazy you ever been in an
all-natural disaster no hell no
where are you from I'm from Louisiana uh
I'm thinking you're from Miami because I
know they'd be having a lot of [__] like
that down here oh I don't know uh well
we have hurricanes what else do we have
hurricanes um
I guess rabies or something I don't know
rabies or you ever seen like a dog and
you bite somebody and then yeah they got
a lot of rabies out there that's a
decent amount I don't know I ain't never
seen them like that yeah what happened
if a dog bites you where they got rabies
uh you get sick you can't drink water
and then you die you can die
yeah I'm gonna have to look that up I
ain't never heard no [__] like that
crazy isn't real honey yes that's crazy
some people actually was getting bit by
dogs and stuff down there oh yeah that's
the thing yeah I would I don't think
it's super popular but it's when I was a
kid it was real popular you know I'm
gonna have to look that up when I go
home well just be careful what you pet
you know because some of these dogs I
don't even be playing like that did you
have any pets growing up yeah what'd you
have
I had two dogs yeah not at the same time
but we'll try to get a dog and you know
how you don't you young you don't really
take care of the dog my mama sold my dog
would have my bag I was having that
came home from school I'm like where my
dog where my dogs at
see I still think about that man she did
wrong she sold two of my dogs ain't tell
me yeah were you a bad owner though yeah
yeah I used to try I was a kid though I
used to be trying but it wasn't like I
didn't know what I was doing like I
remember I had took a string it was a
thin string and I used to walk my dog on
the string and the little thing I don't
know I'm thinking about that
[__] just choking him and he
was still calling his hair I ain't know
I know what I was doing I thought I was
doing something man yeah you was trying
though yeah I was trying that's the
effort you put in yeah for real yeah I
was talking well YG came on the show and
you I was asking I said who's the lady
who's doing well in the rap and he said
uh oh he said sexy rig going crazy I've
seen the interview that's what he said
he is funny no I said you funny oh
thanks yeah he's funny too he's kind of
quiet though yes I think he's a little
quiet but um but he was nice though yeah
um but yeah I saw you and I was like oh
I need to talk to this lady period
thanks for having me I appreciate that
thank you for your time
um so so you grew up in St Louis I know
that you said your mom was at home what
else was it like I got siblings and
stuff it was it was cool like I had a
cool little childhood it was fun but you
know like being in a single parent
household you don't get all the stuff
you wanted stuff yeah well I got a lot
of hand-me-downs when I was growing up
yeah that's what I'm saying like
uniforms shoes on but I don't know
that's just what Heidi is doing with a
single parent I guess dude my mom dated
this guy he was like a mechanic or
something for a while and then two years
later I'm wearing his [__] that's the
mechanic Club it said Mr Mike on the
pocket is it for real yeah
I hit like a growth bird and he was gone
and I was still wearing that [__] yeah I
felt like I was employed I wasn't I was
just in ninth grade and he had a it was
a mechanic shirt yeah he worked at like
a he was wearing like it was a shirt
yeah
yeah it was kind of cool but still we
just had it and it made me and then my
mom got upset because uh I guess she
things didn't end well between them or
whatever but she got mad at you for one
yeah he's like why you got his [__] off
I said well we still had you know I did
but I was happy to have it
um did did your mom date when y'all were
growing up what was that like yeah she
was the day but not like that but we I
did have a step daddy like for a while
but he had got killed like when we was
younger yeah they was going together for
seven years and it was like like you
know somebody we looked up to he he
changed our life for real really yeah he
turned this up he used to um take us
like out of town shopping
oh yeah of course he just was like fun
like a fun parent yeah yeah and he was
so nice
and how did he pass away he I can't yeah
just in a neighborhood or something he
had a house and they came thank you he
had a house and they came and knocked on
um his door and killed him his friend
they backed out him
yeah and so does that kind of stuff
happen a lot like in the the hood or the
trenches people say that a lot is it
really that scary yes them the people
you gotta look out for like your friends
or people cool with you because then be
the ones that's easier to come kill you
like you know you got to watch out for
an enemy so you're not gonna let the
enemy near you right it'd be your
friends the ones you got to really look
out for that's the snake
it's big out there where I'm from though
like everybody get killed by their
friends gosh dang it yeah back dog I
wouldn't mind yeah I don't know if I
would have any I'd just make friends
online then so I don't know
you don't know
who can get shot on Zoom though yeah
yeah somebody came you can't get popped
off over FaceTime you know yeah
um so what about whenever like you
started dating I know you talk a lot
about I've heard you talk about anyway
that you have a boyfriend that's in
prison right no I ain't got no boyfriend
oh you don't no that's my baby daddy oh
your baby daddy's in person we're not
together though that's just my friend oh
I see yeah what was it like whenever you
first started dating and stuff like that
do you remember like the first date you
ever went on yeah yeah I remember the
first date I went on it's just about
like the first day ever in my life yeah
like uh
yeah I think so like I remember my first
date I was I was I went to McDonald's
yeah yeah I was young though and we just
went to McDonald's got some little
McChickens and fries and stuff and we
was like chilling and that was my first
boyfriend really yeah y'all sat inside
or outside we were sitting in the car
but it was like a day like we was like
it was my friend and her little boo
because they was they was friends and
then me and my friend and who had the
car one of the dudes no my friend my
homegirl oh dang yeah she went to go
pick them up and then that's feminism
right there that's girls changing the
game if women are picking you up I know
but it it's like that where I'm from
like the girls is the ones that get
money they're Brave huh yeah they get
the money they're hard workers the
[__] live off the girls where I'm from
oh dang are they doing that yeah that's
a big thing out there
and when does is that do you think it's
just why do they do that I think they
just take trying to take it too easy or
it's just part of the culture I think
girls is like we There's real Hustlers
out there like the dudes we trying to
hustle but they always say it's easier
for us to make money they'd be like it's
easier for girls y'all can do y'all can
go sell some coochie I can do this do
that boys be nice to y'all but us we
gotta get it how we live you know yeah
it is kind of like that they you know
you know what I'm saying do you feel
like girls got it easier than boys
sometimes I think these days with like
women can do I think I guess if you want
to do like only fans stuff like that
would be a stripper or be a stripper
that's true my mom's from the Midwest
and she's hard working yeah she's from
uh Illinois she's from like outside of
Peoria for real yep but she's always
been a hard worker the hardest working
man I've ever known is my mother that's
what I always say man that's how I be
that's how I was with my mama like she
was a real Hustler for real like
when I had my step daddy she was doing
working and stuff and then even after he
died like I could tell it was hard on
her but like she was just like the man
of the house type stuff
yeah my mom's still she dropped for
Amazon she does like deliveries you know
she used to deliver newspapers when I
was young and she [__] throw them
[__] boy
one of her arms was so big bro you're
lying I said don't hit me with you you
was lying I said don't hit me with that
news so she got strong good with one of
her arms yeah that [__] was big
well she was pretty it was pretty big
dang that's kind of tight though and
that's the one I knew if I was
misbehaving a little bit I would get
this one I didn't want to get over there
so that's the one she was throwing the
meal yeah that's crazy that's tight she
would throw him out the window that's
tight dude I remember my mom got a new
car one time she got like a it was
called a Dodge Neon right and we were so
excited man me and my brother we went
and slept in the car that night really
yeah because it was just so clean yeah
that's how I be yeah I was out of we
were probably yeah I was young yeah
maybe nine and eleven or something oh
that's cute you know how when you older
and you get a new car you just want to
sit in there all day even when you're
done driving you're just sitting there
listening to music yeah anything drink
smoke the plane I like being on someone
on an airplane I don't even want to get
off I just let me just stay on a plane
for real yeah just like I just want to
sit in here it's peaceful so you like
playing when it lands when it lands when
we get there everybody
I said bye everybody
you need him go ahead yeah I need you to
leave it right that's all guys I'll be
the last one getting off every time
um so you went on a date I went to
McDonald's and was that like your first
love you think or no yeah it was my
first it was yeah I missed the dude
that's one thing I miss about like
growing older is I try to sometimes I
try and replicate that same thing that
happened when I was a kid I can't you
can't really do it yeah I know what
you're saying like that feeling oh but I
was dumb though I was dumb yeah you know
how you you got a first relationship you
don't really know how relationships go
yo you know what I'm saying like oh yeah
you don't know anything that's good yeah
you don't know nothing so you new to all
this kind of stuff like yeah you lied to
you don't even know when you're getting
lied to because like it's like I'm new
to like I ain't never had a boyfriend
yeah yeah he used to be he was a bad
boyfriend when I got older I realized I
was like dang I was letting him do me
like that and I didn't know I used to be
dumb just believe in him
I couldn't believe how dumb I was well
part of I think part of being in that
kind of love is you have to almost be
we almost have to be dumb in a way in a
way we're done like not in a bad way but
like we're we're naive yeah that's what
it is you know it's like it's almost
like a beautiful type of dumb really
because you you want you want to be in
love so bad you'd willing to believe
anything yeah
um couldn't stand him either your mom
didn't like him damn cause he was older
than me and she just like you know how
your parents know the person ain't right
for you yeah but she didn't like him
because I didn't know I'm just thinking
like trying to take up for him and stuff
she like no that ain't how I go but I
didn't know that though because this
this is my first relationship yeah you
think he's a he's the he's Clinton he's
the Denzel Washington yeah I'm right
here he I just was like he's a hero I
was forgiving him for dumb stuff and my
mom would be like no that's wrong
yeah my girlfriend I remember she was
strong boy she was God was she
experienced or something I don't know
but she was stronger than me which means
strong she was physical or like yeah she
was pretty physical she played I think
maybe baseball you know she was and the
bus would come and pick us up after
school at the end of school and she
would my brother and his friends they
were at the older school so they would
already be on the bus yeah and they come
pick me up and she would pick me up and
[__] kiss me
I don't know not old enough to tell her
don't put me down you know for real you
was just letting her do it it was the
first girl that liked me so I was just
so excited yeah but she she was older
than you she was one year older but at
that time that's a lifetime older yeah
when you were in seventh grade
somebody's in eighth grade that's a
whole That's Another Universe yeah my
boyfriend he was like I was 15 he was
17. so to my to my mama there was
something major she like he experienced
and you just like dumb to the seat down
to the situations yeah he's thinking
about sex probably he's thinking about
he was in the streets too he was bad oh
really oh damn he was bad and did you
have to do drugs or no yeah no
yeah
hey I think we used to be smoking
together oh yeah that's kind of romantic
though yeah I like that
we didn't have a lot of the because I
grew up in our town was pretty much just
kind of black and white children and a
lot of the black girls was more
experienced I think how would you be
they just were more I was always like
intimidated by him really they was grown
yes they'd have a girl one girl asked me
for child support one time in the eighth
grade
that's what I said that's how I beat
them in them household yeah real some of
them yeah that's how I be though when
you growing up in a black household you
kind of learn stuff fast because you
probably got older siblings or older
cousins yeah and they just teach the
young kids like early it'd be like that
yeah and if your parents aren't home
that's a you just learning from the
streets you learn from whoever's around
yeah yeah that ain't good though we were
always learning I guess sometimes good
stuff but mostly just trouble you find
more trouble I think if you if you if
your parents are working where did your
mom work at she was a nurse oh really
yes she used to be at work all day all
she wore was scrubs and Crocs all every
day all day I just like man I can't wait
to get some money I'm gonna buy my mama
some new clothes cause I'm gonna do this
because I just hated seeing her wear the
same clothes every day oh yeah and I
know she didn't really have it like she
had spent her last on us but still be
wearing the same scrubs like that was
her really like her outfit I hated it I
just been feeling bad for her she loved
y'all huh
and does she live she still lives in St
Louis yeah no she lived with me she does
well we got a house in Miami oh wow
congratulations she quit working yeah
yeah I heard her yeah yeah it's harder
to be her mother that's the best thing
exactly she can chill watch her
grandkids you know
yeah you have a child right it is named
Chucky that's a good name for it it's
not his real name it isn't no he's a
real name choice
yeah but Chucky kind of
well Chucky's another sexy red if you
know Chucky the uh little doll it
matched his personality it does it
really yes everybody didn't meet him
wild he got a shank on it he's bad my
son bad it's not even plenty like he
better than other kids I know everybody
that me yeah
that's good it looked a little like them
oh come on I'm not even playing like
everybody that be my son and be like he
act like the real Chucky he's bad
he acts like he's been here before yeah
he do he grown some children are like
that yeah Mama be like this little boy
think he's 22. and if I call him a baby
he only two he'll be looking at other
little kids he like that's a baby and
they'd be his age and then I tell him
come on baby he'll be like I'm not baby
I'm big boy yeah he riding huh yeah you
got kids I don't have any yet I gotta
find a wife here a wife so you ain't on
a wife to have some kids I think I want
a wife I could get I guess I could just
get a baby mama but I've never thought
about that really is it is that you
think it's a better way to do it I mean
if you want to get it over like you
don't got to be married to the person
you have kids with because
I don't know it could just be like a
good friend of yours y'all have kids
together y'all still got their
friendship by and just help each other
with the baby sometimes yeah
you know I've thought about that because
sometimes it seems like almost a better
relationship because then you don't have
to have the relationship involved if you
both know you you're going to want to
care about a child together yeah then
you can do that but it's cool too if you
can have a family too because that's
fine like family can be fun yeah yeah so
a wife with a kid is not bad but it's
not bad also if you was to have a kid
with somebody to choose like in love
with or something that ain't bad yeah I
think I gotta I mean part of me I think
I got to get a better relationship just
with myself still yeah and uh and you
gotta find the right person too you can
just be having babies with just yeah I
don't yeah I've been thinking about it
you gotta make sense I think it'll
happen sometime in the next couple years
but yeah I gotta pray about it too make
sure I get sent somebody that that I'm
gonna also be able to be good to
because I don't want to hurt anybody's
feelings period I'm glad you think like
that because everybody don't think like
that
yeah I think it's hard in this world too
people get everybody gets so caught up
yeah you know this episode is sponsored
by bluetooth yep
sex people are doing it you can do it if
you want
and if you have trouble doing it that's
okay
there's a lot of people that have
Christopher Columbus apparently had
trouble and it's everywhere now even in
the desert people are struggling to get
erect
but you can bring the heat in the
bedroom thanks to Blue chew it's a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra Cialis
and Levitra hey girl
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost
the tablets are made in the USA and
prepared and shipped direct to your door
in a discreet package
Bluetooth wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at
bluechew.com
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code Theo at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast keeps
that's right you want to keep your hair
well it makes sense a lot of us do
keeps can help
yep get expert care for hair loss from
the comfort of your home without ever
visiting a doctor's office or Pharmacy
all treatment plans are personalized to
address your unique needs and
recommended by a licensed medical
provider treatment is delivered right to
your door on your schedule that's the
truth keeps offers both of the FDA
approved hair loss treatment option as
well as a two-in-one gel mmm that
combines both treatments thank you keeps
to date keeps has helped nearly one
million men keep their hair they're
doing it and you can do it hair loss
stops with keeps for a special offer to
get started go to keeps.com slash Theo
or click the link in the description
that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o
whenever you started getting busy what
was kind of the scariest thing like
what's something that's been a little
bit kind of like
I mean I know you said the work schedule
is a lot being around a lot of people
I don't like that I know huh I'm really
shy in real life so when I got to meet
all these people and
being big old crowds I don't like that I
don't like attention like that
are you amazed how it goes from like
because you just try something you put
yourself out there right
um jugs what's one of your first videos
jug jug it's called a slide right the
step slide right the one where you're in
the neighborhood with the gun no that's
that's a thousand Jews that second video
shoot that's
it's hilarious and it's perfect but
isn't it crazy how you if you just try
something how big it can get does that
Amaze you almost kind of yes because I
wasn't trying to rap like I was just
doing some stuff like the first song I
made people was telling me go to the
studio I make a song and then I just
really did it just to do it for me and
my friends then everybody heard it and
was like send me this song and then they
was just sending it around the city then
they wanted to start playing on the
radio booking me for parties I'm like
what the [__] then I didn't make no
songs after that I just was like I was
making little songs but they was just
strictly for me and my friends and then
that's when they just like really start
booking me it's like you're a rapper now
I'm like I'm a rapper I didn't know I
was no rapper
so that's how they came about then
sometimes I won't even do songs he gonna
put it yeah she's pretty that's you oh
my God that's a mess you're beautiful oh
Lord thank you I appreciate that yeah I
looked a mess you're a pretty young lady
I mean the pistol but you know as long
as the safety's on that thing I'll pull
up yeah you funny thank you yeah that's
nice
um so then when did it start to shift
where it really started to like uh
where people started to be like oh this
is intriguing I want to know more
like when did it start to kind of shift
on that video it was going viral and
then I had a third song called chicken
chicken that went viral too like but
they used to be talking stuff but some
people be like this is this is who we
want like this is kind of Miss we've
been waiting on because I guess they be
saying don't nobody make music like how
I make music
so yeah and how do you think you make it
like what's unique I don't know I'm just
myself like
Debbie's saying it's vulgar but I just
speak on what a lot of people be wanting
to say what they don't say it I don't
know I guess that's the thing and maybe
it's like where I'm from too because
that's the sound from where I'm from you
know yeah I got my own style but you
know how different sounds in every city
oh yeah so I got a St Louis sound I
guess something different
I think there's something when I listen
to you I like I I it makes me there's
something intriguing that makes me want
to get to know you I feel like you know
it's like sometimes you listen to people
and you love the music and you love the
beat sometimes you love the lyrics and I
think there's there's elements of that
with you for sure but then there's
something about you it's like who is
this lady I'm there that's what people
be saying but I don't be sometimes I'll
be wondering what's to me like I was in
the mirror and just start in the mirror
and be like why do people mess with me
what's what's up with me like I don't
know I always been a likable person
though really yeah yeah if you liked me
or you was hating on me because like I
was just cool like because you secretly
liked me yeah yeah oh God like eating me
girls that wanted to fight me I look
better than Amazon like they'd be real
ugly but ugly and want to fight me like
what you want to fight me for what I do
to you I don't be on there like I'll be
chilling I'm not a problem starter for
real really I'm not I'm not so lying
like I'm really quiet like I told you
like I don't be so some
what's like a hobby or something that
you have that people maybe wouldn't
think that sexy red does
um I like to draw I know how to paint
I know how to sew clothes yeah my mom
taught me how to sew for real yeah
that's like some back in the day stuff
my [__] look bad though I'll be honest
oh you don't know how to do a thing oh
I'd have a shirt and it would look like
a damn vest I stitched that [__] I did
I show up like that it looked like a
damn frog I make a sweatshirt look like
a damn tuxedo bro my [__] was bad man I
was good for throwing some stuff back in
there I used to make pillows blankets I
used to like if the shirt was too big I
could hem it on the sides make my
jackets tighter like I'd be on it so you
like doing it I love to make clothes and
you like so if you make it closing
you're probably it's kind of like you're
making style yeah
yeah so you've always had your own sense
of style hell yeah yeah there you go
yeah I was uh in a fashion class too and
I was like the Best in Class like the
number one you know the top fashion
person
I mean you have to be yeah I'm just
unique I already know I'm unique like
people be trying to make fun of my style
but I like when people dress how they
feel
like they go with they move you know
what I'm saying well I think black
people are they dress the most exciting
yeah damn you see white people do too
though I think it's it's growing it's
getting better no they be lists like
when I was young like Lady Gaga okay
like that's a good point exactly they be
dressing crazy
I didn't think about that Jared Leto you
ever seen him yeah no I don't even know
who that is but I'm just saying like oh
yeah back in the day even now like they
be dressing uh him he wild and yeah he
always got something I do know him he's
a unique dude he's a cool guy um he was
the Joker
he might have been he brought his own
head over there it was a joker yeah yeah
he's been in some he's been in a lot of
films but uh he always dresses pretty
wild yeah that's what I'm saying I feel
like white people be dressing wow but I
like they style I think it's grow I
think it's oh well you see a lot of
styles are starting to merge too because
like they got now white and black people
I think are there's so many people got
are mixed you know like when I was young
that people weren't as mixed but they
was like like you'd hear like wiggas you
ever heard that term back in the day
wiggas you know white and black people
yeah or blonkies you know I never heard
blankie yes like a black hunky yeah like
a black dude that's trying to be white
like this Chet Hanks right here
he would be like a like a wig I guess
back in the day oh they mean like a
white person trying to be black yeah
yeah they used to have it I'm there and
him Bill Maher where he where he is he
just dates a lot of black girls so I
think that he would classify yeah he
might like the culture
I think he likes it or not he dates I
think he
he likes to date black women he don't
even look like he did uh you don't even
look like he dead hell no yeah I gotta
can you show me a picture with him and
some black girls
yeah let's see who we got
that was his ex-wife huh hell no okay I
can see it now he happy
but black girls stronger too I think so
yeah your daddy's some black girls I
um I've been I have been with a black
woman yeah yeah and I yeah I support it
well he date black people Michael
Rapaport he was just kind of like a he
was like one of the OG kind of wiggers
back in the day yeah he do Echo black
yeah was he a comedian uh yeah he is a
comedian yeah but you said you dated a
black girl before an actor yeah did you
like it yeah I did I think there's I
definitely did was it fun yeah
interesting she only went like on two
dates with me so I think if I went on
more dates with her I think it could
have been fun but it's funny because I
think I used to didn't think about it
and now I think about it more I think
that's one thing about just growing up
and about like experiencing more stuff
yeah you know you start to be open to
more things yeah was it interesting when
he was dating her yeah yeah she had nice
legs too but yes she was interesting
yeah everything was interesting because
it was like a new type of person yeah
like if you sitting there next to
somebody that's like a different culture
and you're not used to dating them dude
it's a whole it's like being at a uh
it's like walking into a new building or
something yeah I know what you're saying
it feels it feels it was it real
interesting yeah what you mean nice
things what you consider nicely she had
strong legs for real yeah she had really
were they long they was just long enough
you know she could stand she was on them
you know
she showed it you know they was holding
her up yeah and that's I don't know if
that's a Wiggy you think Cruella Deville
I don't maybe see not real but she was
she I think she's real enough though she
was Raising dogs at the house too that
counts if you breeding dogs at the house
I think that that counts too I'm dead
what that is this me right here actually
they pulled this one up bottom left boo
you lying come on
boy
Twilight Twilight Zone The Wolf
yeah you right never mind you're right
as hell that's me yeah everything you
look like him oh you right okay I see
you I see me okay you look nice how old
was you wanna thank you I would probably
let me see probably 13. really you look
grown as [__] well I had to be in this
group you had Don Gladys right there top
right he would probably 27. damn and you
13. this was Junior High yeah they put
anybody on that [__] boy everybody in
that [__] that's funny they had
us all Jonathan Smith I used to ride my
bike he would get on the back of my bike
number 19. yeah he was probably 31 feet
tall he'd get on the back of my bike
when I was riding to make me ride him in
the school I did yeah that was fun I
like growing up there I grew up our town
was pretty small and we I like a lot of
black people and stuff yeah it was just
like a good mix you know but they didn't
have
I don't think they didn't have a lot of
a lot of the kids would quit after like
eighth grade I think a lot of them got
either there wasn't as much like black
people doing like a lot of stuff like
they are now
you know they just weren't as
advanced advanced probably yeah you know
they went back in my day either though
yeah like it's just but it's just just
starting to change you think it's
starting to change yeah yeah because
nowadays you see a 19 year old they be
rich wearing Rolexes to school wearing
designers and like when I was their age
there wasn't the thing like it was hard
to get a lot of money like that yeah
they scamming and everything yeah people
finessing everybody yeah they be grown
yeah fast when I was a kid yeah they had
we had a black teacher named Miss Smith
and and then we had uh but they didn't
have a lot of black people doing like
big jobs you know and now ever I feel
like anybody could kind of have any job
yeah me too you know it's changing a lot
yeah yeah
um when you uh what was your first job
uh it was a job called Convergys it was
a call center yeah my sister worked at a
call center that's just Wilderness it's
like High School I knew I wasn't going
to be flipping our burgers or nothing
like that no I can't see you doing no I
couldn't I'm too lazy so I wanted to
have a sit down job yeah
did you have that little mic thing like
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then I
knew I had a house I had a little
apartment and I was doing her and then
I'm like I'm gonna get a job too so I
can save my her money and do what I want
to do and then just spend my work checks
on you know my bills and stuff
what do you think like what skills are
like what ambition where do you think
some of that comes from
like your ambition in life and stuff
because I ain't having when I was young
yeah so I used to be like man watch when
I'm able to get my own winning or when I
turn 15. no I was younger than 15. I
started doing her in Middle School like
girls coming over my house because I
used to do my own hair and girl started
wanting their hair done so I'm charging
ten dollars to do hair yeah anything
thirty dollars just do a quick review
but then I started progressing and you
know I finger weave a Sideburn for ten
dollars boo for two dollars yeah oh God
that's how I was like just doing some
[__] and that's how cause I'm like man I
want I wanted the clothes and stuff I
want new shoes I wanted to be you know
all the kids was coming to the new
school year with their new stuff I'm
like I want some new clothes too yeah I
just started doing her and making money
dude pulling up at school with new
clothes on there with nothing like that
looking clean boy but you had do you
remember times where you couldn't get
new clothes like going to the new school
year you have to wear the same clothes
from last school year well I remember
the second day of school was when I
struggled because I had to usually make
the pants from the first day I had to
bring them back on day two and I had to
convince people yeah right yeah like
these like the same school pants from
last year I write different pants on the
leg of them really yeah
I'm lying online but that'd be crazy bro
and the shoes like you got to make sure
you got all enough pair of shoes for
their first week of school my brother
and I would switch sometimes so when I
got hit mine would be big you know he
was a little older than me so
but I'd be like these different yeah
I'm like this these differences man my
sisters used to swap shoes too yeah it
was fun yeah
um what about so now you have nicer
things was it kind of scary getting
nicer things or you were ready for it
um because you kind of start to leave
like once you get some money in the
world right and I'm not saying that you
have a ton of I don't know anything
about you I mean I know that you're
doing well right you're doing well
enough you can pay your mortgage yeah
yeah but once that starts to happen you
kind of start to leave where you're from
in a way how do you keep from not doing
that I'm still there I'm cheap I still
be I go to Rainbow City Trends and all
this that I shop at beauty spas get
clothes I don't care I'll go to the
thrift store they got some look who you
know I don't I don't like discriminate
like if I see something cute at Walmart
I get it yeah I get I'll just be
shopping so you don't need to have the
fanciest stuff no I don't I don't care
about all the name brand stuff yeah my
team really the people that put me on to
this stuff because I used to be like
shoot for like y'all need me to go buy a
new outfit I got a rainbow or something
yeah but then they start saying like yo
budget higher you can go to designer
stores and then I go in them designer
stores and not even see none I like so I
used to be like
it's not even worth the hype like the
designer stuff yeah yeah I still be
shopping at little stores
I don't be tripping off this yeah
is that your uh is that the watch that
Drake got you yeah no way yeah it is
dang that's the fanciest thing I've ever
seen I know me too I ain't gonna lie
God I never seen nothing like this and
it's see-through
they gotta pull it up what's that song
look at this oh Twitter
dang I wouldn't even put that thing out
the box man
I don't be wanting to wear it for real
like it's it's kind of special because I
never got nothing like this I know right
what like spawned him do you think to
give it to you what made him give it to
me
I'm just a cool person he [__] with me
like I don't know he was excited to give
me the watch too yeah I'm glad he was
excited like that like he's a nice guy
huh yeah I feel like he was just like he
[__] with my vibe and stuff I don't be
on the same like groupie [__] other
people probably be on like I'm just like
chill like that's what everybody know
when they come around me
yeah I'll just be chilling yeah you
chill huh for real dang I like that
that's something I like a chill get a
chance yeah I don't do too much like I'm
just really one of the homegirls and you
like to hug too huh what you mean just
if you hug somebody that is if you got a
man you hug him hell yeah yeah I know
how to make people day like I'm a good
good friend good audit for real it's
important to you yeah yeah to be nice
but I don't know just don't play with me
because I can't get like that like
that's the side they don't want to see
like I'm real cool but once I take it
there y'all gonna wish I never took it
through me because I take it real far
like I go too far I go too far and what
you pull a thing out on them yeah I just
I do all kind of stuff I'm scandalous
for real so that's why I just tell
people just don't play with me like
they're like we can be cool I'm gonna be
I'm respect you just respect me but once
you take it through me
we ain't heading to the moon at all
for real
um and what about when it comes to men I
know you talk about you like a real
strong like a you know a real yeah rough
and tough yeah God it's really you know
a kind of Thug is that okay that term to
use I mean you don't have to be a thug
no I don't have a type okay I just I
like um like a strong a strong dude
though like I ain't got no type though
like he could be a working man but still
put his foot down or be like a stand-up
guy you know what I'm saying he could be
any type of man but just not a weak I
don't like weak people because I'm not
weak like so it's gonna be hard to even
deal with me and I don't want to have
somebody that I can run over you know
that's not fun it's not fun no you don't
want that at all and you don't deserve
that period you deserve a champion yeah
yeah for real
and what about like a white man would
you ever consider dating a white man or
no yeah I don't have like I'm not I'm
not like that I'm not
I don't have a problem with other races
but I never dated no right person really
I always said I wanted to try and see
what it was like
like I ain't gonna lie like I used to be
on PornHub and I used to like watch uh
like white dudes [__] with black
girls because I used to be like I don't
know I just I don't know that's
different to me like you know how you
said sitting next to a black girl you
know yeah it's just something different
like out my comfort zone yeah so I used
to just try to see like what would they
be like I don't know oh I remember the
first time I like uh like yeah sometimes
if you don't spend time around people
there's always like new things you know
it's like little things you don't even
realize like I was telling YG I had a I
went to a doctor's office one time and
the doctor was black right and I'd never
had a black doctor I'd never I'd never
not wanted I just had never you know you
called a doctor you go in there and
whoever comes in is the guy right and I
was like dang I was like I don't know
I know he's a you know but it was just
it was a girl a girl it was a man doctor
okay but it was just I'd never had it
you know so anyway there's things like
with race that I think
some things are just new experiences you
know and so you get you try them and you
see how it goes like if I and when I
went on that date I'd never held a black
girl's hand before you know it doesn't
mean like I'd had a lot of friends that
were black girls growing up but I'd just
never done it until you do it you're
like oh this is yeah it's something
different yeah it's not wrong or it's
just it's something different so I'm new
to you yeah something new so what
happened with the black doctor
it was fun everything was good I got
prescribed and I had I didn't have
anything bad or nothing probably just
some asthma or whatever you know they
got asthma in the black community yeah
yeah really they got it bad damn
bro everything trying to get them yeah
sugar yeah asthma everything bro but
white people got different stuff too
that we can't get like we be looking at
white people like dang they got a lot
going on for real like you know like
they can get lice oh yeah and sunburn
and stuff like I'll be looking at them
like dang that's crazy oh I was thinking
the other day being cancer we can't get
stuff like that yeah and y'all don't
know how sunburn is every people don't
want to admit it but that [__] is real
what it do that's the unsexy red what it
do though
it burned yeah it burn you can't you sit
down you can't hug nobody your body your
skin Be Stiff you pick your child up and
it hurts yeah it's all yeah Sunburn and
sometimes even your lips get burned you
can't even enjoy a little bit of soup
that's crazy it's real people don't
understand this yeah that's crazy
everybody's got their things you know
you know how they have you ever heard
like
um like black don't crack but like we
age different yeah is that you think
that's true I think that there's I think
black is just kind of people wear black
because they want to look
it looks lean it looks it it's a better
color to wear I think
so yes I think it does I think black
people just look better over time look
at some of this damage Dear God
I mean look at this
and he had a shirt on oh look that one
you look at him here's what he got bumps
on his arm so that can happen you can
get bumps oh you could look at that oh
my God it's boils
people they start get you grilling your
own meat that's correct that somebody
had fell asleep with their arm on him
see we don't go through stuff like this
that's what I'm saying we all got our
thing you know
you know why people get diabetes
oh yeah all right I do I thought that
was a black thing we're getting it
people got it I know some people that
got it and they always wearing like
you know they always make it sound like
this and they always have a sneaker
Apple
yeah dude I gotta eat sugar yeah you'll
be talking them their Huff down a little
baby Snicker a baby sneaker diabetes
mortality
yeah so it's happening let me see wait
like Americans whatever nah but you see
how many black like it's real big in our
community yeah yeah that's why that's
why I didn't think white people could
get diet because I just normally hear
about like black people black people get
diabetes yeah yeah I think it's because
we see
a lot
and we put a lot of solder and a lot of
sugar and whatever we eat yeah like we
really season our food like everything
gotta have some you know extra every
every season they're gonna go on
everything you know yeah I think that's
where they come from black people like a
lot of spice huh no matter what it is
huh all the black cultures like
Jamaicans they be putting all spice on
their food
they wild them yeah that's what I'm
saying what's the blackest culture like
is there one culture that's the darkest
skin kind of I think Africans because
they close to the Sun oh Africa so they
like really we can't even go there they
trying to get us there what you mean
dude they got white people in Africa
like you know they sunburned as hell
though oh you think they heard out there
because they're supposed to say oh they
can't even I feel like they just yeah I
think it would be too much they got
white Africans though you know that oh
you ever see the guy that's like a mix
kinda no like straight white like they
white but they speak Africa uh oh they
probably got Chinese people Africa too
oh my gosh can you look that up yeah
look by Africans look up white Africans
and then bring up a Chinese
cause I didn't know that but they got
different different races every every
like you know country you go right like
if you go to China I didn't know black
it was black Chinese people oh wow did
you know that I have not seen it I seen
it it showed black people that talk
Chinese yes
oh you got to get one of them to open
for you
that should be hard yeah it would
Chinese people man like this is what's
interesting about your music is it could
take you all around the world isn't that
crazy
it looked like he black down there yeah
who is that John Payne homie man come on
in Chinese what is going on I don't
understand John Payne he out there can
you look at Blackjack black Chinese
people
we need a couple black Chinese out there
no I seen a picture
they said like they won't show y'all the
other side of uh of China I know yep and
it was like real black people and I was
shocked and they looked just like some
Chinese people but they was black damn
they were slim and they're you know how
the Chinese oh yeah with some nice
little shapes they were straight black
slim pretty I was like Wow Chinese all
kind of they've really come in kind of
one size huh yeah they'd be slim yeah
they're not except for sumo wrestlers
and stuff yeah
but they gotta yeah them boys are big
but I think that's uh
I don't know if they have Chinese sumo
wrestlers they might have Korean I know
they got Japanese
um have you gotten a performer like in
another country yet uh yeah I've been in
London
Canada
um where else did I go I've been some
little places yeah I've been some places
and did yours does Chucky go with you
when you go or no yeah my son be with me
but he wasn't with me in across the
country and stuff because he ain't got
no passport yet he doesn't no I gotta
fill it out only reason he ain't got one
is because they say the daddy gotta fill
it out too like both parents yeah and
you know my he in jail so oh his dad's
in jail this one I'll be saying free my
baby daddy oh yeah that's right huh and
will they free them or not oh no I don't
know
Diddy um did he do it or not I won't
tell anybody
yeah he did he innocent innocent you
know it
of course you know every line yeah
that's how it is they do though oh yeah
look a lot of a lot of people are in
jail and they shouldn't be yeah they put
stuff on people
um
have you been to jail before
not for real like I didn't got locked up
but I ain't had to like do no jail time
right I can get out the next day like
have to spend a night there and then
they'll leave me out like you didn't
start working out or nothing yeah
no like they ain't never seen me to the
back where the other people said I just
be the Holyfield that's the most I've
had to do like 24 hours 40 hours or
something yeah like I'm gonna stay up
front whatever however we figure this
out I'm staying up front yeah I ain't
never had got sent to the back baby you
know businesses grow and they change and
you gotta change you got to be ready
you know even as the world's population
increases Santa's got to have more elves
he's got to get more boxes out
ship station can help
especially right now the Calm before the
holiday storm you can prepare your
e-commerce business for the holiday rush
now by using ship station
whether you're shipping from your house
or a warehouse ship station can help
increase your profitability
that's right effortless integration
everywhere you sell online including
Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify and more
get discounts up to 84 off ups and USPS
rates over 130
000 companies have grown their
e-commerce business with ship station
and 98 of companies that stick with ship
station for a year become customers for
life
go to shipstation.com and use code Theo
today and sign up for your free 60-day
trial that's shipstation.com code Theo
you ever been injured somewhere at work
not at work in a car accident
in a drive-by or something like that
somebody hit you with something hit you
at a rake hit you with a shovel
well Morgan and Morgan can help
they are America's largest injury Law
Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer you
can submit a claim without ever leaving
your couch in eight clicks or less you
can submit a claim to Morgan and Morgan
if you're ever injured
their fee is free unless they win that's
right Morgan and Morgan for more
information go to forthepeople.com
slash this past weekend or dial pound
law pound 529 from your cell phone
that's for the people.com slash this
past weekend or pound law pound 529 from
your cell this is a paid advertisement
today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp that's right
if you've been struggling in your brain
or in your mind or having trouble
organizing things in your life feeling
like you're on track
you're feeling out of sorts
and all those things are pretty common
it's part of being alive if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
make your brain your friend with better
help visit betterhelp.com
Theo today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash t-h-e-o this episode
is sponsored by betterhelp
um do you think one day that you would
get married or no
um I want to just for the experience
because Wellness is fun
and like they just they just look fine
yeah I probably it to me it don't even
awareness is not even real it's just a
ceremony like you can be with a person
y'all live each other you can have a
wedding
y'all break up the next day or something
like weddings ain't real it's just a
ceremony you celebrating your love with
another person basically yeah it's not
real though like I don't know I don't be
believing in all that Mary stuff because
you can sign paperwork and they still
will cheat on you and all that like yeah
is married people giving a wife's AIDS
and stuff you know what I'm saying like
if y'all got married that was the whole
point of like committing to each other
so y'all don't gotta do that but people
are still doing it yeah so it's like
what was the point of getting married
right so I don't know yeah I think it
would be fun I think it would be nice
like an experience but I don't think you
got to be that serious it could just be
me and this person been together for a
long time we want to celebrate our love
in front of y'all but it ain't it ain't
even got to be like okay now we married
it just be a little ceremony you know
yeah like a party oh yeah I like that
yeah
um that's how I see it do you think that
there's a
that there's a chance that you'll go
like start to do your own tour I know
that you just got to open up for Drake
right yeah that was yesterday I got a
song coming up you do
yep
I do see how this Princess tour
coming soon oh I've seen y'all I'm sorry
I've seen some of the flowers I saw it
out twice yeah it's already sold out
twice yes because the first time they
didn't think he was gonna do what he did
it sold out within like 30 minutes to an
hour and then they went to bigger Arenas
and then they sold out so now people
still looking to buy tickets but they
sold out so
and do you start to like think about
like what do you want on it like do you
want like the screens how is it gonna
look and that sort of thing
yeah I've been thinking about we've been
thinking about all day this last night
that's you huh yeah wow
he's aware
that's so cool
too Bob
did you feel nervous or anything no huh
I don't be nervous no more it's fun I
used to be nervous because like I said I
was shy but now I just do what I got to
do yeah once you start to get used to
especially if the venue is bigger at
first it feels real scary but then once
you get in there a little bit you're
like okay yeah I'd be nervous I just
want to get this over be like my heart
rushing but now I'll literally just go
up there and do like I do maybe it's
because I know how to crowd gonna react
to me I used to be scared thinking when
nobody gonna like me I think that's why
I didn't used to want to do it yeah it's
fun to go out there when you know
they're gonna like you yeah what if they
don't um wanna see me like what if they
just sit there and watch me perform
because I didn't have times where I
first started rapping and they don't
know my music so everybody just sitting
there just watching me and I'm on stage
still having to act like I'm just when
really inside I'm just like I'm ready to
get the [__] off this stage like they're
not even [__] with me but they were
smoking me they just didn't know my
music and then I get off the stage
they're like I really like your music
where can I find you at and I'm like oh
so they was [__] with me I just
didn't know yeah yeah yeah it is scary
well it's interesting just the different
levels you go through and then once you
get to a certain level you never get to
really go back to those yeah you don't
really realize at the time sometimes
that those that there's like uh how
interesting they are or just how like
how some of those moments you might
never have them again yeah you know I
used to be so scared to the point I used
to like throw up like before I got out
of stage or after like hurry up we gotta
rush off stage and run right to a trash
can like my anxiety would be bad damn
yeah it's bad really it's still kind of
bad like I don't like walking through
crowds like people ignorant they'll pull
your hair try to hit you like they just
you know you just never know I'm
grabbing you too huh yeah they be
grabbing me and I don't like that like
don't touch me and I got anxiety already
and then everybody want to grab touch
all on my arm pull up pull them away
the [__] is wrong with people
crazy
when you um when you think about like
doing art and doing something new right
do you start to does your brain start to
think of like new avenues and things you
want to do or do you just kind of are
you kind of happy in your lane or like
I'd be wanting to do something
everything I'd be like I want to do a
cooking show
I want to start a fashion line I want to
sell this but I always been like that
like ever since I was little I knew how
to make money like when I was a kid I
used to sell chips go take all my chips
from the house go sell them at school
for a dog
like I always been a hustler so I'll
just be finding ways to make make money
yeah that's always been me yeah they got
a good cooking so have you seen Sean and
Marley they do cooking no signing Worley
yeah these Two Fellas in uh Australia
and they got down syndrome
oh and they got the best cooking show
they be making some good some good food
oh it's good man
oh they're so cute yeah pull up a clip
of it if you can man when I go to
Australia I want to go on their show for
real yeah they do good Sean is uh
he wore to lead Marley he's good too but
I like I love both of them yeah
what they making when they live together
they friends yeah they're friends and
they have I I don't know if they're
brothers or not they look alike yeah
they might be brothers but that they
might
yeah I'm gonna start watching it they
good I'm gonna start watching on
Instagram they're the best and yeah they
do all kind of stuff they do chicken
they do dessert we look so good I'm home
they do uh
oh it's so cute they probably got their
parents behind the camera helping them
something yeah some of the knives they
can't use but most of the stuff they can
use and they do a good job yeah they do
all kind of fun stuff
um but that's one of my favorite shows
yeah I wonder who you would cook with or
it would just be you maybe with
celebrity guests or something just
coming on there like cooking their
favorite meals and stuff or showing them
what we eat in my household like oh yeah
yeah I like cooking I like to make
Italian food and I like pancakes too you
like pancakes yeah you like a random
yeah yeah you like them huh I like syrup
you do you put syrup on a lot of stuff I
love it you ever had White Castles uh
yeah I've had him oh my God I get a
cheeseburger White Castle cheeseburger
at science and dip it in some syrup
so good I ain't lying you gotta try it
that's good then you gotta taste it it's
so good do you smoke
well it's still good even if you don't
smoke because I used to get hot fried
and just go to White Castles and did my
little hemorrhoids
bashing because that's the one of the
late night spots we got where I'm from
yeah so everybody got a white like the
White Castle line be rapping all the way
around
yeah I'm trying to think of what we went
to we went to yeah maybe Waffle House
they had a Waffle House in our town and
the police would pick up all the drunk
drivers and they wouldn't take them to
jail they would drop them off at the
Waffle House why just because I think
they didn't you know they was trying to
be nice to them so you go in there to
eat and it would be full of all the
drunk drivers were sitting in there what
just waiting just drunk as hell just
trying to sober up you know no that's
too much it was pretty it was
interesting I bet that was like yeah
like they in our Friday night drunk
that's too much that's
what about uh did you ever get met did
you ever have any drug issues or you
just drank and smoked mostly I don't
drink I smoke oh you just smoke you
never like drinking I used to drink when
I was young but I stopped drinking like
this stuff nasty I had bad experiences
off liquor so I just when I smell it it
just stole me off like I don't even want
none of that can you get pretty high
like what's the highest you can get you
think
super high
so where I go to sleep like I got a high
tolerance and I can just keep smoking
like if me and my friends just rolling
the backpack I'm not gonna turn it down
I'm gonna hit every blunt like
that's a lot it's all damn yeah I can
smoke I can smoke like a chimney
and um I think black people are better
at getting high do you think so why is
that they just uh we yeah
maybe so it's a thing it's a it's a
thing it just I think some people are
better with certain things you know like
Asian people can't drink alcohol they
turn red
yeah I think white people is good
drinkers white people I think it's
probably good drinks they good drinkers
they known for the drinking for sure and
they like psychedelic drugs too like
like I was thinking that too like with
like mushrooms LSD but there's a lot
more black people getting into mushrooms
and stuff now because I just found out
about them I ain't too much new about
all this stuff but yeah like you said
yeah but that is kind of like a white
thing like if you watch the movies and
stuff yeah it'd be the white people
putting their black friends onto the
[__] like yeah right
about all this [__]
[Music]
X might be both black and white I think
black people doing it now but I feel
like white people is the suppliers or
like they really good at this [__] like
yeah if a dude's pulling up to sell them
it might be a white dude probably
they had a lot of Chinese people are
doing uh ecstasy ecstasy what's ecstasy
sex pills right I was just saying that
yeah same thing oh okay the Chinese them
boys are getting them boy and they get
wild I'm dead
at the Rave in China people struggling
to control ecstasy dang they turn
somebody boy if I wonder what kind of
drug I would like to do if I were
Chinese I wish I could be different
cultures you know wouldn't it be so cool
to just to know what it's like yeah yeah
switch cultures and [__] just wake up or
get inside somebody else's body I really
wish you could do stuff like that and
take it for a drive like a car yeah like
trade bodies with people yeah yeah but
what if you got a little bitty body like
they got a there's only fans models that
have some only fans like a little person
there they are a [__] and they making
Banks she said she made it they like
people like me is that actually it's
like
oh yeah
20 million a year in a year since you
made 20 million in a year that's kind of
creepy though like people be saying like
it look they look like kids that's not
yeah that's not cool you can't say that
you got to say hey you look like an
adult
no they they gonna say they look like
kids so they want to [__] oh that's [__]
do they have a lot of like pedophiles
and stuff in the black community or no
same I know it's to me it's big it'd be
really in your family too
the black people like that's where I
know all the rapists to be in family
households and stuff oh really yeah yeah
wow your uncles yeah oh all cousins once
I find out I was an uncle I was like
damn I can't do this man what you mean
it's just because you always hear about
the crazy uncle or that you know yeah my
brother's like we're having a kid all
like [__] man I'm dead all right it's
fine though being an uncle it's fun but
yeah I'm glad I'm not this my nephew so
they're good
but that is so cute they are cute
they're so cute how old is they they
sweet kids they 11 I think and nine yeah
they are they're nice children actually
yeah I've been pretty blessed you got
nieces and nephews mm-hmm
they they're first kids it's when uh
when you have a kid coming to your
family it kind of changes things yeah
they do it definitely do it kind of
bring them together too though like it's
a new new person in the family it's kind
of weird too yeah it's funny did you uh
get closer to your siblings that had the
children yeah because we had to be there
for my sister and help her out you know
it was fun though
yeah it's fine what's something that you
would spend your money on now that
you're making some that I would think
yeah
can I drink these on camera yeah sure
that I would
um
the most expensive thing I didn't bought
is um a house yeah in a car
that's the most expensive thing and I
never expected to be doing stuff like
that so I know it's kind of weird like I
guess I have to do it you know or not
have to but I should get myself
something too because I work hard yeah
but that's like I'm I'm the type like
that'll be my if somebody's like what
you want I'm gonna say some stuff that I
need not stuff that like give me a purse
no all right I mean this for my house
give me this like you know give me
something I need yeah yeah something I
can use peripheral not just no purse or
no clothes or shoes no I need some real
stuff like yeah yeah I need some
ingredients that's what I need
they said 15 things worth buying
skincare oh yeah skin care
I would get something nice like a a
watch
I don't know no man oh yeah yeah it's
like comfortable stuff too when I get a
nice little house shoes
black people love house shoes huh yeah
these model house shoes I wear these
everywhere oh those are cute huh thank
you oh cause they red too huh no I got
them for my because that my son he loves
Spider-Man do those fit him too no no he
wished they did
I got them for him
though do you uh does he sleep in your
room or he have his own room he got his
own room but he he just want to sleep in
my bed all the time dang I like get out
of my room I be telling him maybe no
oh my God we had this argument every day
he'd be leaving food all in my bed
crumbs his toys that's his room for real
I can't have no privacy for real does he
out do you think he would want a sibling
or he has little friends and stuff he
don't got enough friends he got cousins
and stuff I think he'll want a sibling
but yeah he would he like playing with
other kids and it's just him and me so
and my mama he need other kids to play
with so I think he would want to Sibling
yeah
he could be I follow this one kid on
Tick Tock I don't follow a child but
it's like his parents do it you know
samaj that's his name you ever seen him
no he make this he's like
smaa J on Tick Tock so Myers what do you
do his mom like puts like like
conditioner on his skin sometimes at
night
and he goes he's so beautiful no you
haven't seen him no oh he's cool I gotta
see him you know some people their kids
are just real funny that's him yeah the
one on the top right that's him
this kid is funny man
at least
we came here
you're beautiful
oh that's cute
this week
oh
you greeting it up he's the best I know
some of them are huh that's how my son
be like he had grown really yeah I get
my hair done he'd be like I like your
hair like he always pointing I I even
forgot I didn't got my hair done and he
appointed out he'll be you're her mama I
like it
thank you he's like you look cute you're
cute you look pretty were you scared
when you first had him or no
yeah because it's like a new experience
like damn I gotta look out for somebody
oh my God I was crying thinking about it
like my life is changing and you got to
set your alarm the next day even because
you got to get up it was a big change I
was depressed too
I was depressed and then what happened
he started growing more into a person
and it got easier yeah it just got like
fun and interesting but I definitely was
depressed when I first had them like I
was really sad I don't know why well
that's called postpartum because I
wasn't used to it so it's like dang it's
a human I gotta take care of it's hard
yeah and knowing this like finna be with
me for the rest of my life like I'm
finna get I can get a house I got
another person I gotta look out for
everything I'm gonna get food now I
gotta buy this person some food it's
just like it's hard
yeah I guess and if his dad isn't around
that's probably the toughest part
because he can't build that relationship
it is tough yeah being a single parent
like even if I know I got it like I got
the funds and stuff to take care of my
son but you can't do daddy stuff like
and my son always asks for his daddy so
this is just hard I hate it for him
yeah and you can't even rent a debt you
can't do nothing like that yeah no he
know his daddy yeah
you can't even play like this yeah yeah
oh that's a bummer dude they have like
con do they have like visits where you
can go visit or no yeah we'll be
visiting them oh that's cool right
behind glass oh man so they can't touch
each other my son be putting his hand on
the window he'll bring his toys and be
playing on the toys I'd just be crying
like this is so sad I hate that for kids
kids deserve their parents yeah and they
make a difference when you got your
daddy in your life too it really does
yeah because they used to the Mama being
nurturing but when you got your daddy
it's like damn you got a daddy that's
different you know yeah that's different
yeah especially I think in poor
communities like a lot of the other kids
in our neighborhood we didn't have some
people had dads and you could tell there
was a little bit of a difference in the
home you know yeah that's what I'm
saying like it's it's different like
dang you got a daddy like you look you
blessed you look you got both of your
parents in your life I know I always
admired that I like to be over there at
those houses yes too yeah because I had
a friend
she was the only one that had her daddy
stealing her wife and when I say she was
spoiled we used to go to her house she
had a big old house she had all the
snacks all the clothes like she was just
like living life like it was fun going
over there her parents was the best for
real yeah my friend William his his dad
was there and we would go he sometimes
his dad would spank him I'd be like
spank me I like like you want them to be
your daddy yeah I just want to end yeah
okay I didn't want to feel a little Yeah
just something yeah oh and they yelling
at you too too it's like now you part of
them like yell at me yeah yeah you want
to be a part of that family they also
yeah it's nice it's important yeah damn
for Christmas she used to have all the
toys all the good gifts
[Music]
it's sad to say but it's a blessing if
you can have both of your parents it
shouldn't be like they're like yeah I
think it's one of the things that's
tough in the world is like people can't
even if you know it used to be able to
be a mom I think it used to be able to
be that a mom could be at home with her
kids and now both parents they even have
to work if you do have both of them yeah
you know it's like they've both got to
be there yeah
[Music]
um
but I think that's beautiful that you
want that for your son it's important
yeah and I yeah I think I would probably
like to have that when I have a family
yeah for so you got to be a stand-up guy
because Daddy's is important yeah yeah
that's the thing I got to be ready to be
a daddy
it's important though you know I gotta
want to get up in the morning and say
yeah yeah put my shirt on Mr Mike I'm
gonna be that man you know yeah you
can't be no lazy bro it ain't no such
thing
no they keep you up working you gotta
play with them all day get a bath
you basically gotta treat them like
another you know like it's you like yeah
whatever you do for yourself no actually
no because you might want to lay around
all day and do nothing but your kids
they want to be active they want to do
this do that and you gotta actually be
ready to do you got to be engaged with
them yes yeah every time but I sit there
and still play with him like I'm his
friend or some
put them in the tub he hungry all the
time he always wants juice oh he always
wants something yeah he want to go to
the store I'll just be doing damn yeah
um I got a couple more questions for you
what's a topic that we wanted to get on
Nick you see anything on there
wow oh yeah did you see this wow what's
crazy is we was I swear to y'all my son
I was just in the car before I got here
talking about Tupac and Makaveli because
I was like y'all know people I ain't
saying he did but I was like y'all know
people really do fake their deaths and
stuff like to get away from Fame because
I can understand that because Fame it's
like
yeah I was I think of death too to get
away from this [__] yeah
because it's just a byproduct of success
a lot of times especially in this day
and age you know where everything's so
visible but yeah they said that this guy
I think he'd been going on podcasts what
was his name what did he say kef d
ude he's long been known to
investigators as one of four suspects
identified early in the investigation he
isn't the accused gunman what was
described as the group's ringleader
he was in the car Davis himself has
admitted in interviews and in his 2019
tell all Memoir Compton can you scroll
so that's what I got is dumbass Compton
Street legend that he provided the gun
used in a drive by wow he's so dumb he
went all these years without getting
coffee you're gonna go on there on the
interview thinking she cool to talk
about but do you think that you're crazy
he might be do you think though that he
did it because does it say that he's
dying
he had cancer
[Music]
on his deathbed type [__] yeah he
thought he was dying of cancer so that's
why I think he started to talk more
about it that's crazy and that he came
alive but now he's still alive and in
jail now
that's crazy
it's crazy
uh what do you think about that what
were you guys talking about it when you
talked about it we were just saying like
because people used to be trying to act
like they spotted Tupac here in there
and they were talking about he not
really did yeah he like the black Elvis
kind of yeah oh they said Elvis didn't
really die yeah people say he's here and
there people seeing him at Dollar
General do you I think stuff like that
could be real we just never know like
anything is possible to me oh yeah I
wouldn't be surprised maybe if you had
enough if you had enough money and
enough Connections in the media you
could make it happen like um what was
that repute was this not Epstein yeah
they were saying he not dead for real
remember they said somebody killed him
and himself yeah they said the cameras
were off the guards weren't there and he
died he hung himself
I don't know people were saying he not
really did he just got all that money
and he got he probably somewhere living
life on the other side of the world
right now and he looks like the kind of
creep that they would let loose in this
yeah in this world
man when he talked there's one thing
about it so I don't know I believe it's
possible that people can fake their
deaths and just gone about their way
yeah that's possible but you if somebody
sees that guy though it's going to be a
wrap but you know they could change
their face it's things like that now
really
people probably yeah they get surgeries
and all that change how they look change
their identity when you got money yeah
you can do whatever you want to do
because let me get some money and commit
a crime and let me have a lot of money
like a billionaire and I need to do this
to do that baby I'm a new I'm not even
that person I would I don't know what
kind of what surgery would you get you
think tahad um probably like a face
reconstruction you might find a breast
reduction too really he might have no
yeah to change everything like you
better show up yeah thinking like she
had big titties if people see them cups
they might know what she is you know
they see them red Solo cups baby yeah
I think uh I would get a maybe a longer
neck
and people be like is that him and
they're like no that won't make a
difference he will he got that long ass
yeah look at right there hey she coming
up
dang suddenly she's a good swimmer the
internet is looking at her I said okay
swim you think they're gonna make me
float he did that for real girl yeah
start a job as a fairy the internet and
I buy a ticket
come on it's crazy
I think I like a kind of like a moving
butt like butt that's something I got
some activity too yeah like a butt that
looks busy like it's about to run off
and do something
you're funny yeah so you'll be looking
at booties and stuff yeah I like looking
at probably some booties I don't really
care I mean I'll breasts are great I'm
happy that people have breasts I like
both yeah maybe I like I mean I'm happy
that everybody I'm happy that women have
them yeah
yeah I like yeah I like I like all of
that me so I like like a curve
curvaceous yeah it's cute yeah I got I
got I got some cheeks on me too so I you
know I do yeah you got to have some buns
I think even though your girl squeeze
your buns maybe if we making like dinner
or something do I grab your booty
yeah maybe I don't know is that too much
no it's not
I mean it's the person you're with they
can touch wherever they want to on you
like yeah
if that yeah if that if this if this if
y'all getting along well I think it's
nice
yeah why'd y'all pull that up man yeah
that's me I know that ain't you they
trying to that's real yeah they kind of
is that your real ones yeah why they
look fake I it looked like you poking it
out on purpose
what is you doing on that that's how I
look so you was just standing there yeah
yeah my friend it looked like you
straight going like this somebody took a
fit they shouldn't have done it I'm dead
yeah
what uh what other topics we got Nick
what else some other things and we'll
get you out of here sexy okay you
performing tonight
um no I got a studio session you do yeah
then I got a flight early in the morning
so when you go into Studio sessions like
how do you find like new beats and stuff
these days are people just could it be a
stranger submitting something or you
gotta like people send it because they
can't send it to me because I'm not
gonna see it everybody try to see me
stuff I just say send it to my team and
they gonna show me and I'll sit there
and go through the beats and if I'm if I
could catch a flow in my head or start
rapping off the top then I'm like yeah
that's I want to have this beat yeah
yeah and do you start do you start to
get paranoid a little bit about not
paranoid but do you start to like
because now people these days people
consume things so quick you want to put
out some you know I feel like especially
if you're a creative person you want to
put out the next thing you know yeah but
I don't even think I ain't gonna lie I
don't think too hard about it I just
I just do me any work for me for real
like I don't even think hard on it like
I just go with my mood have I'm feeling
a day if a [__] do something with like
I had experience I can go right about it
and it might be a hit for real because
the real stuff be the hits like when you
really making a real song oh yeah yeah
then be the hits like pound town
I knew that was a hit because it was
like a real story so I'm like they gonna
like they gonna relate oh yeah I
definitely I know about it yeah and
everybody know about Pound Town downtown
everybody know about that and how do
people get to Pound Town exactly do they
I mean I know it's like sex right but at
what point does sex turn into pound town
I guess I mean if it's good like if
y'all doing this [__] like doing the
damn thing yeah it got to be good though
if you if it's not good you wasn't in
downtown for sure if it was whack that
was not Pound Town yeah I think I've
been on the outside I've been in the
suburbs probably you know what you mean
you ain't never been to pound town I
mean I've been uh you know yeah it's up
to you too well it's up to both partners
for real like if it's just like magical
yeah that's pound town oh maybe I've
been yeah I probably
I've probably been through there then
yeah yeah I think I gotta fight the vibe
gotta be there for both of y'all yeah on
both ends like she can't be whack you
can't be whack you gotta be just lit up
all the way you know yeah yeah that's
pound town for sure oh yeah you have a
pleasure I'm just thinking I'm trying to
yeah I'm making sure I've been there I
have been yeah yeah but yeah I think a
lot of yeah I've been there yeah I
enjoyed it serious
um well let's look at a few we got a few
other sexy ribs I think did we find some
way
the Big Red Dog that's Clifford right
there you know we want Trump to a sexy
red people talk about I'm dead
sexy Reds I'm just saying hey do you
think more people are going to support
Trump now and then hood or no yeah they
support him in the hood because at first
I don't think people was [__] with
him like they thought he was racist
saying a little [__] and you know
against women but once he started
getting black people out of jail and
giving people their free money
oh baby we love Trump we need them back
in office yeah that a little bit of free
money goes a long way we need him back
because baby them checked oh yes them
stimulus checks Trump we miss you that's
like whoa Vicky she's always talking
about Trump you see her ever I like
Trump no I ain't never seen one she
funny
to me like I used to watch his interview
not interviews like him talking to
people he's be calling people fat yeah
wow he funny like we're too many people
like him well I got to meet him one time
at a UFC fight have you ever been no I
want to I would go to a fight would you
if I invited you to go sometime hell
yeah yeah I like to see some fights man
yeah look I would sit there I'll stand
by if [__] gets weird I stand right
behind you oh my God you know but if you
need me I'll come around front but I'll
start in the back so you didn't went to
some UFC fights yeah I love it you would
love it I do I want to go it's like the
trenches but nobody's getting really
only people that's getting hurt or
planning on it man and that'd be real
too like so much fun but he walked in
him and Mike Tyson came who was that
that's Donald Trump that's the real
Trump yeah at a UFC game yeah and he
came in wow he's silly man I know I want
to meet him he looks short is he short
he probably doing okay I think older
people start to get a little shorter oh
I said that yeah that's crazy he was
pretty chill
he was just yeah he like just seems like
a fancy kind of a fancy guy he funny but
he was pretty funny he said
actually told YG this I tell he said oh
he goes you're doing good you're doing
great right and I was like yeah and he
goes uh your father's doing how's he
goes how's your parents I was like my my
dad's been dead uh for maybe 20 years he
goes but before that he was doing great
I was like Trump is a character
he ain't know what to say yeah crazy man
yeah
uh he died of cancer damn I know what
about your dad
um I still got a daddy oh you do yeah
does he live in uh St Louis yeah oh nice
yeah we still cool and stuff nice is he
pretty proud of you
all my family proud they like you the
first person from the hood to make it
this for like to wow hey like you know
how many people from the hood used to
just rap and put out videos but didn't
get nowhere with it and you doing all
these big things like they really she
put me on a high pedestal out there and
don't you feel a little bit like part of
them is inside of you when you're doing
stuff yes for sure that's the same way I
feel it from my neighborhood I just feel
like everything I do there's a little
bit of like my friends from the area
that's in me you know I'm still I still
go over there but my team don't really
want me to because it's not safe for me
no more but I still be trying to be
normal and go over there but I'm not
normal no more I'm not so but yeah I
know it's kind of it's kind of a bummer
huh in some ways yeah because I still be
wanting to be regular like sometimes I
hate being famous for real I just like
the money
yeah yeah being able to pay your bills
is definitely nice and not having to
work a real job oh yeah that's great but
the fame everything that comes with it
I don't like it it's a lot I think Fame
and certain things they sound more
exciting and everything than it actually
outside yes then in the actuality of
things it's just kind of like
it's fun but it's the the ideas of stuff
like you get free stuff you get you get
in for free wherever you at you can go
eat it live a fancy life but it's stuff
that come with that yeah right
everything you got is not everything
that Glitter Is Not Gold you know what
I'm saying yeah so yeah it'd be some
[__] with this [__] yeah I think I'm so
excited for you sexy I'm glad that I got
to meet you thank you it's nice meeting
you too what's a product that you think
you're I would like to see you come out
with like a crayons you know yeah I got
a lot of [__] I want to do they trying
to come out with me some hair dye like I
said yeah that's fair crazy sexy red
crayon color they thought sexy red Kodak
Black you could have okay and now I'm
trying to think of all the different
crayons yeah coochie pink yeah you can't
play with it yeah kid yeah you might
have to yeah yeah I might have to like
do some [__] um
yeah that's a fair color that's a
definitely a that's a special tent no it
could be the white color yeah I'm trying
to think of who else could be like a
last name that has a color
Bobby green he's a UFC fighter I don't
know Bobby green he's cool
um
I don't know who else that's him he's
good I've seen him before he's uh he's
good I definitely want to go to you I'd
be watching him on Facebook okay maybe
kicking each other in the head punching
I'm serious it's real it's not wrestling
uh-uh oh it's the real stuff oh it's not
boxing because they really hurting each
other boxing is I mean boxing is serious
too but this stuff boxing is but you
this is hand in hand like you busting I
I'll be seeing it man you would love
that I think you would really I do I
like to watch fights I'm gonna try to
bring you to a fight let's do it I'll
let you know talk to my team about it
bring me to a fight it'd be really real
yeah I am I'm gonna uh I'm supposed to
see Dana White next month and I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell him okay you can
definitely go to a game I mean I say the
game a fight together you can call it
with you when I look and once we get
there I'll tell you kind of what's going
on if you need some information okay
um sexy red thank you so much
congratulations thank you yeah I'm just
glad to get to know you I was excited
about it and sorry if I've been a little
bit nervous I think I have been but you
ain't nervous I feel like I was like
low-key today no I thought it's okay you
know sometimes that's the thing about
podcasts you just kind of show up how
you are yeah you know and that's what's
nice about it I appreciate you just
showing up how you are I appreciate you
for having me yup thank you yeah thank
you
[Music]
Cornerstone
oh but when I reached that ground I'll
share this piece of mine I found I can
feel it in my bones
[Music]